[Music]  [Music]  on the force I'm gonna take it a fight  at a crime but to crack this case a baby  panda was stolen and they're using the  dog so was a front for animal smuggler  hmm I'm working undercover he'll have to  be Best in Show whoa Ziggler the  flashing zip toilet water  mm-hmm he can't do it alone I'm  deputizing both to you  a team of crime fighter with license to  bust so he's calling all birds to easy  and fashionista sashay away  duty calls  breathe how we are cooking with gas from  the director of Beverly Hills Chihuahua  the Smurfs and scooby-doo is that bikini  wax what  [Music]  now this is while being a movie stars or  lappa show dogs  [Music]  you